sur ce plateau didier le reste
conseiller pcf de paris et ex secrétaire
général de la cgt cheminots bonsoir on
vient d'entendre le premier ministre et
qui dit ne pas avoir peur je cite du
chant breizh promis par l'opposition la
porte parole de la république en marche
leur berger a jugé pour sa part qu'il y
avait aussi pour les oppositions un
enjeu de crédibilité en portant je cite
des projets alternatifs on sait que le
pcf veut pro vous présenter un
contre-projet prévoyant un âge de départ
à la retraite à 60 ans est ce que le pcf
2 devra montrer qu'il n'est pas
seulement dans une logique d'obstruction
non non je pense que le parti communiste
français a pris l'initiative avec
d'autres partis de gauche pour
construire un projet alternatif au
projet de réforme du gouvernement qui à
la fois contesté par la rue contesté par
une majorité de citoyens et de
citoyennes en france et y compris
maintenant d'ailleurs torpillé par le
conseil d'état et il faut remonter à
plusieurs décennies pour avoir un avis
aussi violent contre un projet
gouvernemental par le conseil d'état
donc ça veut dire que le j'entends le
premier ministe qui encore droit dans
ses bottes mais il faudra aussi qu'on
s'entende sur ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie il ya la fois la démocratie
politique mais aussi la démocratie
sociale et je pense que le parti
communiste et d'autres partis de gauche
ont aujourd'hui effectivement le mérite
de dire nous on veut pas de ce projet de
réforme de ce système à points qui va
conduire effectivement à faire baisser
l'ensemble des pensions de retraite
mais par contre nous sommes nous avons
des propositions pour améliorer le
système actuel et nous avons un projet
alternatif y compris nous faisons des
propositions de financement
alors justement le pc avec le ps
elle fit également les députés donc du
coach qui veulent déposer une motion de
censure commune contre le gouvernement
il faut 58 signature sur 577 députés
c'est possible mais tout à fait je pense
que d'ailleurs quand je regarde
aujourd'hui la réaction par exemple des
partis politiques au sénat peut-être
demain à l'assemblée nationale qui
n'accepte pas cet ultimatum du
gouvernement qui les met devant un fait
accompli
c'est à dire que le gouvernement veut
procéder ce qu'ils appellent par la
procédure accélérée
c'est à dire de ne laisser très peu de
temps aux parlementaires pour
appréhender le projet et est fermé et
proposer des amendements
donc c'est quand encore à un déni de
démocratie et et ça ce n'est pas
acceptable
donc je vais vous dire quelque chose le
président de république réfute bien
naturellement l'idée de dire qu'on n'est
pas dans une dictature bien
naturellement qu'en france on n'est pas
dans une dictature telle qu'on la
connaît dans certains pays sauf que nous
sommes dans une société de plus en plus
violente qui est d'ailleurs alimenté par
ses politiques
je dirais austérité air du gouvernement
et du président de la république qui
effectivement le engage le passage en
force
c'est à dire on passe au dessus des
parlementaires au dessus des syndicats
ont l'opinion publique aujourd'hui plus
de 60 % dit il faut retirer cette
réforme le gouvernement pour aujourd'hui
n'en tient aucun compte et donc il ya à
la fois aussi de la répression il ya
deux du mépris de la condescendance de
l'arrogance donc tout ça ça alimente
aussi une société violente ou de plus en
plus une société radicaliser donc il
faut aussi quand même quand on est
responsable politique prendre la mesure
des événements
il y a
comme vous le dites une mobilisation qui
perdure dans la rue on le voit
aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore les
chiffres la semaine dernière vendredi
c'était 2 149 mille à 1,3 million selon
les chiffres des autorités ou des
syndicats c'est un fait mais également
la grève dans notre côté qui
s'essoufflent un trafic normal à la ratp
ou à la sncf
comment expliquer ce paradoxe non alors
ce qu'il ya c'est il faut savoir
d'expérience dans un mouvement qui
social qui dure dans le temps il y à des
fluctuations qui a naturellement les
salariés des transports singulièrement
les cheminots et les agents de la ratp
qui ont eu plus de 45 jours de grève on
passait le relais à d'autres secteurs
professionnels et c'est pour ça que sur
les territoires aujourd'hui nous avons
des actions multiformes qui se développe
nous avons à la fois les territoriaux
les ports les raffineries
nous avons les hôpitaux nous avons la
culture nous avons les agents de de
l'énergie et tout ça est donc tout ça ça
entretient effectivement si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi
la flamme et le mouvement va continuer a
duré d'autant que si le gouvernement
veut continuer à passer en force et je
pense que rien n'est réglé de ce point
de vue une flamme comme vous dites
à l'appel des syndicats aujourd'hui la
cgt fo en tête il y avait également ffs
eu solidaire des organisations de la
jeunesse
or le taux de syndicalisation en france
et de 11% les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur qui date de 2016 qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des 89 haute pour cent
restants alors on a un paradoxe en
france par rapport à d'autres pays
puisque moi j'ai été aussi responsable
syndical européen et j'ai pu comparer je
dirais les histoires les traditions et
les pratiques du syndicalisme ans au
regard du taux de syndicalisation en
france on peut dire mais il ya des
raisons
je dirais externe et interne pour
expliquer le taux de syndicalisation qui
est bas mais il ya aussi une force de
frappe qui n'a rien à voir avec le taux
de syndicalisation on dit en france 10 %
de syndiqués mais les organisations
syndicales en réunis sont en capacité
dans des mouvements sociaux de mettre
des millions de personnes dans la rue ce
qui n'est pas d'ailleurs le cas dans
d'autres pays européens qui ont beaucoup
plus de syndiqués que les syndicats
français
voyez ce que je veux dire donc il faut
raison garder mais par contre il ya des
raisons qu'on n'aurait pas le temps
d'expliquer certainement ce soir
pourquoi il ya un taux de
syndicalisation qui est jugé
relativement bas en france
merci c'est le mot de la fin didier le
reste je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller de paris du parti communiste
français et ancien secrétaire général de
la cgt cheminots